can dans la commune de Saint- Joseph et
depuis
1989 la CAN
àc que repr mon depuis 1999 on est parti
en retraite et est
570 et ben dans la campagne comme il
prend des gens coup du coup
moi plutôt l'administration les
papierers pour la
déclaration regarder s'il courpe ou pas
de la
journée on campagne c'est le désage
l'engré
emmener tout qu'il fautir pour la canne
repoussere en fait mais quand il
replante ou quoi que ce soit c'est au PO
can
pas ben l'avantage la CAN à su c'est ça
si vous pas obligé on n'a pas des
erreurs des horires fixes à venir et on
est pas obligé non plus d'être là 24 he
sur 24 comme pour l'élevage ou quoi que
ce soit donc il peut organiser Mo comme
il peut comme il veut aussi quelque
part voilà ce que all faire c'est
d'avoir réussi d'tre encore là jusqu'à
maintenant que Ch que me pensait pas au
début com l'
pris ce que M aime c'est être dans la
nature êre avec la terre en contact avec
la terre son moi dans mon élément quoi
c'est quelqu'un qui aime à l'extérieur
et bouger manuellement c'est quelqu'un
de très manuel donc voilà ce
que